so let's talk about the fed hikes that
took place this week okay and
for some people they're like well what's
the big deal with this we're going to
talk about that here in a minute so
fair hikes benchmark interest rates by
three quarters of a point the biggest
increase since 1994 this is a cnbc story
on wednesday they launched its biggest
broadside yet against inflation raising
benchmark interest rates three-quarters
of a percentage point in a move that
equates to the most aggressive high
since 1994 the rate said setting federal
open market committee took to levels to
of its benchmark
to a range of 1.5 to 1.75 the fed's
benchmark rate will end up at 3.4
that compares with an upward revision of
1.5 percent point to march estimate the
committee then sees the rate rising to
3.8 in 2023
a full percentage point higher than what
it was expected to be in march officials
also significantly cut their outlook of
2020 economic growth now anticipating
just a 1.7 percent gain in gdp down from
a two point eight percent so adam you
see this to the average person who sees
this
okay
0.75
how does that affect me but to somebody
that's been in financial industry for a
while what does this really mean to the
average person so
what i talk about like for instance
let's just talk about what the fed is
right we're talking about the fed rate
of rate hikes so
at the helm of the fed is jerome powell
chairman of the fed he's been there
since the trump administration uh now
he's in there biden kept him and then we
got janet yellen who is um
secretary of the treasury and then you
got biden so those are sort of the
three-headed monsters basically
controlling the monetary supply right
now uh what's the purpose of the fed so
obviously you know they're they're they
control the money supply we've seen how
much money they've printed over the past
three years right how many five trillion
bucks that you know just boom right
there so we can touch on that
you had a debate with the father the
godfather of quantitative easing you're
not a fan of that i assume right you
don't want to you don't want it i'm not
i'm not a fan of
bailing out the people at the top and
complainers 100 that's not what i'm a
fan of the people at the top are big
boys
and the people at the bottom need to be
inspired by people in the middle who
actually do the day-to-day work to make
money pay the bills support their
husband their wives their kids pay their
taxes send their kids to school raise
their families become good citizens
america's ran by the people in the
middle that are quiet that don't get a
lot of recognition those are heroes and
sometimes the guys at the top and the
guys at the bottom complain weighing too
much
the doer is nothing you know what i mean
by the guys at the top
you know what i mean by the guys at the
top i don't mean to i don't mean the
doers no no no
there is the the complainers
there is those in the middle that are
just doing the day-to-day job they don't
need the recognition they just want to
go out there and do their part okay tell
me what the guidelines are i'll go find
a job i'll go get better i'll go pay my
bills i'll go be a good citizen
there's the creators and the initiators
who are at the third level who are the
future they're the ones that make things
happen they're the ones that make things
better they're the ones that innovate
make technology better make products
better make systems better make our
lives better that's third level and then
there's a people at the top who used to
do that and now they haven't for 20
years and they just keep doing buy back
buyback buyback and they found a way to
maintain their wealth at the top that
they're no longer in the creation and in
in initiation mode and they're taking
money from taxpayers who say build me
out those guys shouldn't be billed out
those guys ought to go out of business
and let the market decide who's the next
future to come future the country that's
my problem with the guys at the top and
the complainers at the bottom makes
sense yeah so the interest rates go
ahead you were saying well so basically
the purpose of the fed is uh you know
stabilize unemployment stabilize
inflation stabilize um
economic growth or obviously it's not
stabilized hopefully there's you know
gdp increases i think there there's now
predicting it's going from two they're
predicting three percent down to like
1.8 whatever but the fed has a role okay
so at the on the macro perspective this
is what the fed's doing that's what
drool pal is doing how does that affect
everyday people okay so
it's gonna affect everyday people in one
of two ways you're either going to want
to have lower prices or higher
interest rates okay so
what i so in being a personal finance
expert i talk about the seas of debt the
seas of debt what are the seas of debt
credit cards car loans and what i call
cribs mortgages so if like some people
if you know what you're doing you'll go
get a mortgage if you don't know what
you're doing and you're just kind of
figuring out it's like i got to get a
[ __ ] so borrowers people who have debt
people on the lower rung of society this
is not a good look for you what's
happening right now that's great if
you're a saver like me who saved money
and is debt-free
this is a very opportune time to
capitalize right now so for instance i'm
looking at this and i'm like i feel for
the american people i feel like there's
been a lot of fake money that's been
printed and has been earned over the
last few years you know an nft i just
bought it for 300 grand i'm gonna make
him now your nft is worth 30 grand good
luck if that okay crypto's been cut in
half we all know the game stuff it's not
cut in half more than half oh ethereum
is down 78 percent okay so even but
bitcoin's been cut in half or even more
they're 60 grand 60 percent you're right
you're absolutely right so i'm trying to
give crypto people to benefit the doubt
less than half more than half but if
you've actually do what i talk about
have a budget maintain cash flow you
understand your income and your expenses
you stay out of debt you work you earn
you actually put in the work you don't
just sit home and collect unemployment
you've saved you've invest you have your
financial house in order this is a
major major opportunity to capitalize so
i'm looking at this and i'm thinking
okay all right i haven't bought bitcoin
in since 2018 i got in when it was very
low
and i haven't bought i've been looking
at the prices i've been seeing these
[ __ ] people who don't do anything and
they're just kind of crypto rich a lot
of the gen z and i'm thinking
now i'm gonna go probably buy like 510
bitcoin boom all right at 20 grand a pop
all right cool so if you've got your
house in order this is a major major
buying opportunity but if not if you're
like most americans 78 of americans are
living paycheck to paycheck they're
struggling you know
this is a rough time for you but you've
had two three years to kind of get your
[ __ ] together and if you haven't
hey it's on you what are they talking
about the k-shaped economy the rich have
gotten the richer the poor getting poor
to your point
bad policies have what consequences have
consequences so they've they've printed
five trillion dollars if you've taken
this time to say all right you know i'm
gonna i'm gonna double down on what i do
i'm gonna get better at what i do i'm
gonna save my money i'm not just gonna
go spend it and just like
ball out on random crypto nfts and i'm
actually going to just figure my stuff
out and work and not like take the easy
way everyone wants to get rich quick
these days me i've been saying this for
years for years people are like what do
you mean i want to get rich slow so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]